and good evening from Washington the
willful blindness of the left and the
wake of terror attacks that's tonight's
angle every time there's a terror attack
liberal politicians and their partners
in the media come down with a sudden
case of amnesia they react as if random
jihadi attacks have never happened
before yesterday this news beck
immigrant mows down innocent people in
New York yells Allahu Akbar at the top
of his lungs it leaves a series of notes
in Arabic suggesting he murdered in the
name of Isis and yet some in the press
are left scratching their heads Becky
why would have an animus toward the
United States
what Oh might as well ask as an uber
driver why would he have anger toward us
some will do anything to avoid the
elephant in the room we've allowed
adherence of a poisonous train of
radical Islam to enter the United States
and they're plotting to kill our
citizens whom they consider to be
apostates but why learn from the past
and grapple with reality when we can be
comforted by Stephen Colbert tomorrow
and the next day New Yorkers will wake
up to new details about what happened
but tomorrow and the next day New
Yorkers will also wake up and keep going
because in an uncertain world one thing
is for sure
New Yorkers will never live in fear and
if that bromide doesn't calm your nerves
today mayor de Blasio picked up where
Colbert left off we understand this was
an attack on our values it was an effort
to break our spirit but as an effort to
break our spirit it failed but of course
New Yorkers are resilient they survived
and rebuilt after 9/11 Mayor but this
misses the entire point
why must any Americans suffer or die to
satisfy the liberal dogma of diversity
remember this is McMurdo got here
through the diversity visa program it's
a kind of immigrant Powerball it allows
50,000 or so winners a fast pass to
citizenship and access to all our
government freebies today following the
New York terror attack the president
resumed his call to end the diversity
visa program I am today starting the
process of terminating the diversity
lottery program we want a merit-based
program where people come into our
country based on merit and we want to
get rid of chain migration the
president's talking sensible immigration
policy but the left of course wants to
demonize him or just talk about their
own agenda the notion that you want to
focus on a visa waiver program or a
extreme vetting politicize this tragedy
in the morning after I think that's a
sad day for this country
the president's tweets I think we're not
helpful I don't think they were factual
I think they tended to point fingers and
politicize the situation I think it is
madness
the number of assault weapons that we
have in this country I hope one day
we'll have a federal policy that
actually brings sanity to the gun policy
laws in this country gun policy what is
he talking about since the terrorist
instrument of choice of course was a
rented truck should we ban them as well
governor the reason these folks avoid
the truth or divert our attention to
these side topics every time we
experience a terror attack is because
the reality the current situation
conflicts with their own warped
worldview the government's chief
responsibility is to secure the homeland
which in turn protects the freedoms that
we all enjoy but on the left there is
one value that seems to trump all others
even safety it's the D word all of those
immigrants make America more American
that diversity that we have is a
strength in our country we are the best
problem solvers in the world our diverse
is a strength this is the cult of
diversity and it's led us to this
dangerous program without which eight
innocent people would be alive today now
remember what Chuck Schumer said back in
2006 in defense of the Visa Lottery
in fact my city of New York has
dramatically benefited from this program
and diverse countries such as Ireland
Poland Nigeria have had large numbers of
immigrants be able to come settle roots
and really help the diversity of New
York and the diversity of America yeah
you left out who's becca stan in that
list
well tears flowed down Senator Schumer's
cheeks remember back in January when the
Muslim immigrants were affected by the
president's travel ban we're worse tears
today people don't need politicians
crocodile tears or their cliches
Congress must act and stop this madness
Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell rather
than losing sleep over the fate of the
daca kids they should shut down this
diversity visa farce now before another
American or tourist or country dies and
that's the angle